Ein Drittel der Zweitliga-Saison ist gespielt und es zeichnen sich erste Trends ab. Nachdem wir letztes Mal auf den Abschießkampf geblickt haben, blicken wir dieses Mal auf das Aufstiegsrennen. Geht Schalke 04 mit dieser Muslic-Magie hoch? Was ist eigentlich mit Hannover 96 los und ist Hertha BSC nach dem Sieg in Kasaslautern endgültig back? All das jetzt mit mir, Nele Hüpper und Matthias Kneifl. Let's go!
Und nun im Programm– der Rasenfunk.
Lagerheim fliegt vorbei und der Ball ist im Tor. Und Augsburg ist oben. Rossis zu kurz Abwehr, lang genug für Willi Landgraf. Wagner, Martin Wagner.
Und das 1-0.
Markus Kurt aus dem Gewühl.
Alexander Schur! Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Sorry, da muss ich kurz reinhängen. In dem Spiel ist mir das so krass aufgefallen. Gerade bei Darmstadt, weil ich Darmstadt in den letzten Wochen doch öfter gesehen hab, als mir lieb war. Der Spiele-Öffnende-Pass kam vor allem über die rechte Seite, über Korridor, aber die Aktion nach vorne, die ging eben über die linke Seite, über Marseilla. Und das hat mir richtig gut gefallen, da die Spielverlagerung zu sehen, wir sind einfach auf der rechten Seite, Spieler ist stärker, aber wir benutzen die linke Seite auch und binden so einen Spieler gut mit ein. Und das hat mir in dem Spiel gegen 96 richtig, richtig gut gefallen.
Nur gegen 96. Und das ist eine perfekte Überleitung, die ich nehme, weil sie mich zu meiner These und dementsprechend Frage an Matthias führt. Denn man sucht bei DarmShirt verzweifelt nach Statistiken, in denen die richtig gut, aber auch richtig schlecht sind. Alles bewegt sich in einem sehr mittleren Korridor. Ha, den musste ich einmal bringen. Bei Expected Goals ist man beispielsweise auf Platz 12. Bei Großschwank sogar nur auf Rang 14. Gleichzeitig vergibt man nur die vier wenigsten. Also hohe Effizienz ist sicherlich ein Teil des Erfolgs. Aber bei Ballberührung im gegnerischen Strafraum ist man auf Platz 11. Bei zugelassener Expected Goals ist man auf Platz 9. Bei Ballüberroberung im letzten Drittel auf Platz 7. Bei abgefangenen Ballen aber nur auf Platz 12. Bei den Laufstatistiken ist man sehr im Mittelfelder Liga. Und trotzdem steht man da ja, wo man steht. Und ist das vielleicht das Geheimnis, wenn wir uns beispielsweise Marceler angucken, aber auch ein Liedberg, aber auch ein Hornberg, Marco Richter, dass es Florian Kohfeldt vor allen Dingen gelingt, ein solides, defensives Gebild zu bauen. Kein perfektes, aber ein solides. Und er ist vor allen Dingen seine größte Stärke als Trainer aktuell ist, taktische Situationen zu schaffen, in denen sich dann die individuelle Qualität von diesen Spielern am besten entfalten kann. Also im Sinne von, ich gebe dir einen gewissen Raum, und in dem darfst du dich dann aber frei entfalten und eigene Entscheidungen treffen. Selber entscheiden, wie du ins Tripling gehst, selber entscheiden, wie du dich in den Raum bewegst. Aber davor, das ist vorgegeben. Oder bin ich da auf dem Holzweg?
Gute Frage. Ich glaube, das können wir nur spekulativ beantworten. Ich weiß zumindest, als ich mit Frazier Hornby gesprochen hatte, das war zugegebenermaßen im Frühjahr, aber da hatte er gesagt, weil er schon gerne nicht in vorderster Front stürmt. Er sieht sich als mitspielenden Stürmer, der dann durchaus auch mit in die letzte Kette den Spielaufbau mitträgt. Und da hatte er gesagt, dass ihm Kohfeldt immer mit an die Hand gibt, gegen welche Gegner er so was machen kann. Also eher aus der 10er-Position heraus zu agieren und wann er eben vorne bleiben muss. Er gibt ihnen offenbar schon klare Empfehlungen an die Hand, wie sie sich innerhalb des Spielsystems gegen den jeweiligen Gegner orientieren dürfen. Und ich glaube aber, dass er aus der letzten Saison sehr viel einfach mitgenommen hat. Weil wir erinnern uns, er kam, es gab diese Kohfeldt-Tabelle, dann ging es in der Rückrunde im Rückwärtsgang gefühlt ans Tabellenende oder Richtung Tabellenende. Man war nie so richtig in Abstiegsnöten, aber auf jeden Fall ging es nicht voran. Und ich glaube, dass dann von Kohfeldt einfach so die Quintessenz war. Wir müssen im Sommer und auch von den Verantwortlichen den Kader nicht umbauen. Wir haben eine Struktur gefunden. Wir haben einen Kern gefunden, auf den gilt es aufzusetzen. Und dieser Kern muss einfach verstehen, worauf es in der 2. Liga ankommt. Seriöse Arbeit, Konsequenz in Verteidigungsarbeit, aber auch im Torabschluss. Das passt so ein bisschen zu den Zahlen, die du genannt hast. Und wenn man einfach so eine Grundstruktur hat, die um ein paar Facetten erweitert wurde, wie ein Akkiyama, der sehr, sehr ballsicher ist, der viele Pässe-Spiele laufintensiv ist und jemanden beklefisch neben sich hat, der viel wegarbeitet, dann kann das schon mal im Übergangsspiel sehr von Hilfe sein. Und Kohfeldt setzt dann schon auch immer wieder gerne auf einen festen Kern. Also er ist keiner, der jetzt ohne Not durchrotiert. Also deshalb auch, du hast Marco Richter erwähnt, der war gestern jetzt gar nicht am Start. Der enttäuscht bislang auch eher ein bisschen von meinen Begriffe. Also diese Erstliga.
Das sieht ihm so unähnlich.
Ja, du weißt, wovon ich spreche. Also das, was er selber für sich wahrscheinlich in Anspruch nimmt, ein Erstligaspieler zu sein, das kann er bislang in Darmstadt noch nicht so unter Beweis stellen. Deshalb ist er im Moment gar nicht so ein wirklich großer Faktor. Das heißt aber auch, Maßeile und Koldore machen es so gut, dass es eben richter schwer hat, reinzukommen, wenn keine Sperren oder Verletzungen am Start sind. Und diese personelle Stabilität, die tut dem Spiel der Ligin einfach gut. Also sie haben jetzt Leute wie eben die genannten Akiyama und Clefisch auf der Doppel-Sechs, die Vieren vorderster Front, hinten in der Innenverteidigung, mal Dreier, mal Vierer, mal Fünfer Kette. Aber das funktioniert und deshalb ist es schwer zu besiegen. Das ist in der zweiten Liga womöglich immer schon ein kleiner Teil des Erfolgsfaktors. Und jetzt kommen aber gleich wohl auch schwere Gegner. Ich würde jetzt schon fast vorweg nennen, dass Darmstadt für mich kein Ausstiegsfavorit ist. Also ich sehe sie als ein Team, das so im ersten Drittel mitwirken kann. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass sie ein Ausstiegskandidat sind. Sie sind gefestigt. Sie wissen, was sie für Lern aus der letzten Saison mitnehmen mussten, sowohl offensiv als auch defensiv. Schon war da jemand, der mir kurz vor der Sommerpause gesagt hat, die Mannschaft muss einfach lernen, lernen, lernen. Und dieser Lernprozess scheint einfach verniedlicht worden zu sein. Und man hat jetzt einfach ein paar Punkte liegen lassen durch Unentschieden. Aber die Siege waren in Summe überwiegend gerechtfertigt. Die Niederlagen auch. Aber zwischendrin hätte man auch durchaus ein bisschen mehr mit einsammeln können, als es die Rémi schlussendlich hergegeben haben. Jetzt ist es, wie es ist. Sie sind in einer guten Position. Auch hier alles kann, nichts muss. Aber ich denke, in letzter Konsequenz wird es stärkere Teams geben, die dann schlussendlich mehr Punkte aufs Konto schäfeln als Darmstadt.
Ich gehe da, glaube ich, auch mit. Also mein Bauchgefühl, wenn du mich fragst, Darmstadt 890 ist das erste, was ich sagen möchte, Platz 5. Ich glaube, dass sie bis zum Ende oben dran sein werden, dann aber immer noch zu viel über individuelle Qualität funktioniert. Also du bist natürlich sehr abhängig davon, dass ein Liedberg beispielsweise knipst.
Und da wissen wir gar nicht, ob er bleiben wird, weil sein Vertrag, also er weckt Begehrlichkeiten. Ich glaube, der Vertrag läuft nicht aus zum Sommer. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die Ligen verkünden einfach nicht mehr Vertraglaufzeiten. Aber wenn es einfach so ist, er will vielleicht auch noch auf den WM-Zug aufspringen, falls sich Schweden über irgendwelche Umwege qualifizieren sollte. Er ist jetzt wieder für die Nationalen Herrschaft nominiert, erstmals nominiert, bislang war er immer nachnominiert. Das heißt, er ist zumindest mal auf dem Zettel und dann kann man sich anderswo vielleicht nochmal auf einem anderen Level beweisen. Wenn er den begehen will und dann schon eine entsprechende Ablösesumme generiert, kann es natürlich sein, dass wir in der Rückrunde nicht mehr so einen Knipser haben, der jetzt nicht in jedem Spiel brutal auffällt, aber der einfach die Tore macht, was auch wiederum diese Expected Goals und Effizienzwerte, die du aufgeführt hast, erklären. Die sind in seiner Person sicherlich mit zu erklären. Und deshalb mal schauen, wie die Rückrunde sich dann tatsächlich gestaltet. Also ist er noch ein Bot fein, wenn nicht, dann viel Glück. Dann nimmt es ihm keiner übel, weil er ist einfach ein hart arbeitender Spieler, der nicht nur irgendwo abwartet und dann was reinmacht, sondern der auch viel mitarbeitet. Also das ist vielleicht auch noch so ein Aspekt der Arbeitsetos bei den Lilien, der ist schon sehr ausgeprägt. Also man nimmt nichts für gewiss, sondern man arbeitet dran, den Erfolg einzufahren.
Nele, was ist so deine Prognose für die Lilien bis Saisonende?
Ich glaube, die können uns noch richtig überraschen. Also ich glaube, Platz 3 ist auf jeden Fall drin, würde ich mal sagen.
Also gibt es Anhaltspunkte für?
Ich glaube, sie kann halt auch Teams wehtun. Das ist so was. Vielleicht nicht über 34 Spieltage hinweg, aber Spitzen-Teams können sie schon auch beschäftigen.
Und wem sie wehgetan haben, sind ja nur Veraner, die Überleiterin Memmich. Auch da haben wir den Vorteil, dass es zum direkten Duell kam und wir direkt darüber reden können. Nele, du bist ja durchaus auch mal dran an Hannover. Aus verschiedensten Gründen.
Gezwungenermaßen.
Gezwungenermaßen, so ist es. Hier fiel dieser Satz schon wieder, den ich so oft höre über Mannschaften von Christian Therzisis. Sie waren eigentlich gut drin im Spiel. Sie haben eigentlich ihre Aktion. Aber dann kommt es zu Unnachlässigkeiten. Das sind ja mittlerweile fast schon Phrasen zum Titspiel. Wie hat dir Hannover in dem Spiel gefallen? Hast du das Gefühl, dass es nur daran scheitert und ansonsten schon sehr viel in die richtige Richtung geht? Siehe auch Saisonstart.
Jetzt muss ich noch mehr aufpassen, weil Weihnachten steht bald vor der Tür. Sonst kann ich mich zu Hause nicht blicken lassen. Nein, Quatsch. Ja und nein. Ich glaube, wir sind uns alle sehr einig, dass wir diesen Rausschmiss von Leitel nicht verstanden haben zu diesem Zeitpunkt. Christian Titz war ja in Magdeburg auch wirklich alles, es war ja nicht alles scheiße, was der gemacht hat, ganz im Gegenteil. Und das, glaube ich, ist halt in Hannover jetzt auch so ein Stück weit das Problem. Diese interessante Anfangsphase, die ich vorhin so bei Darmstadt schon habe mit einfließen lassen, dieses wirklich gnadenlose Pressing, dieses hohe Anlaufen, dieses hohe Gegenstehen, das kostet Kraft. Und wenn du das nicht, wenn du nicht, wenn du, ich versuche gerade das Wort Spielermaterial zu umgehen. Personal. Das ist ein ganz furchtbares Wort. Ja, aber wenn du mit deinen Spielern das nicht so durchziehen kannst, wie der Titzball das erfordert, und der erfordert das halt nun mal, dann hast du Probleme im Kader. So, und das ist bei 96 auch nicht das Neueste, dass die Probleme im Kader haben. Alles in allem, man hat ja dann auch gesehen, in der zweiten Halbzeit stand Hannover dann wieder sehr, sehr tief. Und Darmstadt musste rennen. Also Christian Titz ist, finde ich, ein sehr guter Trainer, der sehr gut nach Hannover passt. Und ich hoffe wirklich, dass er die Zeit und dann irgendwann auch den Kader bekommt, dass die halt aufsteigen können. Weil Hannover zeigt ja, dass es eigentlich auch geht. Aber es fehlen halt noch so die letzten 5 bis 10 Prozent, die aus dieser grauen Mausstadt-Club einen wirklich großartigen Bundesligisten macht.
Und das ist ja irgendwo verständlich, denn es gab ja den Radikalumbruch im Sommer samt neuer Spielidee. Und ich glaube, dann erkennt man auch erst im Pflichtspielbetrieb, die und die Zutaten fehlen uns noch. Ich finde, eigentlich hat man jetzt schon einen sehr guten Job gemacht, was man da sich rangeholt an den Spielern. Also allein Bundu ist so eine Bereicherung für diese Liga. Das kann schon richtig Spaß machen. Und wie gesagt, sie haben ja auch wunderbar begonnen. Sie haben 5 Siege zum Saisonstart geholt. Aber seitdem ist halt richtig der Wurm drin. 8 Spiele seitdem, 2 Siege, 3 Unentschieden, 3 Niederlagen. Und auch immer abwechselnd. Also ein Toho-Wabuhu dahingehend. Mit Ball ist man nach wie vor richtig gut unterwegs. Man hat den höchsten XG-Wert der Liga, bei dem man erschwiegt sich die meisten Großchancen, hat die drittmeisten Tore, den zweitgrößten Ballbesitz, die zweitmeisten genauen Pässe und auch die meisten Ballberührungen im genrischen Strafraum. Also man bekommt den Ball extrem gut, flüssig ins letzte Dritte. Das ist ja, glaube ich, die größte Stärke von Christian Titz. Das war es auch schon bei Magdeburg. Aber da sind wir dann wieder bei den Feinheiten. Und das zeigt sich dann so ein bisschen auch beispielsweise bei Elbersberg. Die zweitmeisten vergebenden Großchancen. Also man ist nicht, man hat nicht diesen Killer-Instinkt, den es bräuchte. Vielleicht hat man da auch nicht den richtigen Knipser. Also ich finde zum Beispiel Kellmann, der ist super. Aber er ist nicht der Knipser. Also der macht dir dein Tor, hätte aber in jedem Spiel gefühlt eher drei machen müssen. So in dem Dreh. Und gegen den Ball wiederum ist man zwar aufmerksam, aber auch da fehlt oft die letzte Konsequenz. Man ist Platz 17 bei Torverhinderungen. Also so geblockten Schüssen, diese Dinge. Diese letzte Verteidigungsaktion. Da hat man auch bislang einfach extrem Nachholbedarf. Und ich glaube, das fasst das Ganze zusammen. Und eine Personalie muss man besprechen, ohne dass es immer an einem Spieler hängt. Torhüter Neu bislang leider die drittschlechteste Quote bei parierten Bällen und Platz 14 bei verhinderten Treffern. Jetzt hänge ich.
Aber du bist wieder zu hören.
Jetzt bist du wieder da.
Oh man, heute ist wirklich der Wurm drin. Jetzt steht mir hier Christian Titz auf der Leitung. Ich glaube, es sagt… Nein, ich hatte gerade die Nau in den Neuen besprochen, falls man das noch gehört hat. Drittschlechteste Quote bei parierten Bällen und Platz 14 bei verhinderten Toren. Also es fehlt irgendwie an diesen letzten Ecken und Kanten des Spiels. Tore machen, Tore verhindern, alles dazwischen. Mega, fast Erstliga-würdig. Aber da vorne und ganz hinten, diese letzten Aktionen, und das passt ja auch wiederum zu Christian Titz, denn auch das war an Magdeburg oft das Problem. Da fehlen irgendwie die letzten Prozentpunkte. Und ich glaube schon, dass er in Hannover mehr Ressourcen bekommen wird, also im Sinne von nächste Transferperiode, um diese Probleme irgendwann auch personell zu lösen. Aber aktuell verhindert das, dass Hannover wirklich die Liga so dominiert, wie sie es vielleicht sogar könnten.
Ja, irgendwie sehr symptomatisch fand ich irgendwie so das Zerstandekommen des 2 zu 2s in der zweiten Halbzeit. Darmstadt kommt da irgendwie sehr engagiert aus der Kabine und die Niedersachsen stehen einfach super tief, so habe ich ja eben schon gesagt. Aber der spieleöffnende Pass kam aus der eigenen Hälfte, der zum Tor geführt hat. Und Hornby hat fast 20 Meter, vielleicht sogar mehr Platz, wo er wirklich ohne angegriffen zu werden gehen kann. Also und da hat man, da sieht man so, finde ich, dass es war sehr symptomatisch, wie, mit wie wenig Kontrolle und mit wie wenig Gefahr nach, also Gefahr, Bewusstsein 96 da agiert hat. Weil von da an ist die Partie auch, also ist auch wirklich abgeflacht. Ich habe da ein bisschen vorgespult dann zwischendurch, weil es wirklich nicht mehr der Hurra-Fußball war, der es dann in der Schlussphase dann auch war. Aber das war wirklich, also das fand ich irgendwie sehr symptomatisch. Es ist nicht das erste Gegentor auf diese Art und Weise, wie 96 sich das gefangen hat. Es wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht das letzte sein. Und da einfach zu sehen, ok, wenn man einem Spieler wie Korridor, oder wie Hornby, die auch diese Qualität für die 2. Liga haben, wenn man die einfach laufen lässt, dann ist man auch ein bisschen selber schuld, wenn man sich so ein Gegentor so fängt. Und das sehe ich bei so Titz-Mannschaften jetzt nicht zum ersten Mal.
Das passt auch zum ersten Saisonsieg von Hertha. In Hannover hat man 3 zu 0 gewonnen, aus dem Nichts. Also zum einen hat man das Glück, dass Hannover in der ersten Spielhälfte nicht effizient genug ist. Und auf der anderen Seite wusste man, dass Hannover defensiv durchaus unaufmerksam sein kann, viel Raum hinter der Kette lässt, und man die ganz schnöder auskontern kann. Und so gewinnt Hertha dieses Spiel völlig glanzlos, auch etwas glücklich, aber irgendwie wieder so, dass man sagt, ja, schön doof, Hannover, mit 3 zu 0. Und das hat dann bei Hertha vieles ins Rollen gebracht. Aber genau das, was du sagst, Nele, man kann, sie sind so, ja, fehlendes Gefahren, Bewusstsein ist eine wunderbare Bezeichnung dafür, was Hannover bislang irgendwie ausmacht. Und das, wie gesagt, zieht sich bei Titz ja seit jeher so ein bisschen durch. Und dann müssen wir darüber reden, was wir daraus irgendwie machen. Denn irgendwie sind die Probleme bei Hannover, also das, was gut ist bei Hannover, und das, was schlecht ist bei Hannover, das ist seit Saisonbeginn dasselbe. Und deswegen tue ich mich so schwer, zu sagen, wo die am Ende landen. Ich kann sagen, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die Platz 6 werden und sich richtig ärgern, weil da richtig viel liegen gelassen wurde. Ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen, dass die Platz 2 werden, weil die Dinge wirklich ineinander klicken. Und die dann verdientermaßen, weil sie diesen Fußball spielen, diese Liga doch noch überrollen. Ich finde das so schwer. Matthias, hast du einen Anhaltspunkt?
Ja, finde ich auch schwer. Sie zehren ja gewissermaßen von ihrem sehr, sehr guten Saisonstart. 12 Punkte aus den ersten vier Spielen, dann kamen jetzt nur noch neun hinzu. Das bedeutet, bei ihnen klickt es gerade auch so ein bisschen im Negativen im Kopf. Sie wissen einfach, dass es schon in vielen Spielen in die Hose gegangen ist. Zweimal recht deutlich, wobei ich das Spiel gegen die Hertha auch zumindest gegen Ende verfolgt habe. Und da war Hannover nach wie vor sehr zielstrebig, bis ins letzte Drittel auch da immer noch zu Chancen gekommen. Aber irgendwie geht es nicht auf. Und wenn sich das so ein bisschen verfestigt und sie nicht den richtigen Schlüssel finden, dann wird es die Saison auf jeden Fall nichts. Dennoch haben sie so ein positives Herangehen an ein Fußballspiel. Also gestern war es ja wirklich sehr unterhaltsam, weil beide Teams, glaube ich, die Chancen schon im Offensiven gesehen haben. Gleichwohl ohne das in der Defensive jetzt zu vernachlässigen. Aber irgendein Team musste dann zwangsläufig einen Fehler mehr machen. Ich bin gespannt, ob Titz, was man ihm ja auch so ein bisschen nachgesagt hat, bei Hamburg ging nicht in letzter Konsequenz in die richtige Richtung. In Magdeburg wurde der letzte Schritt sozusagen nicht gemacht. Auch wenn sie zwischendurch eine ziemliche Delle hatten, als sie auch schon mal im Abstiegskampf zwischenzeitlich sich fanden. Da hat er dann wiederum die Kurve gekriegt. Aber der letzte Schritt, der ist bislang von ihm so in der Form nicht gegangen worden. Und ob das jetzt in Hannover funktioniert? Also im Moment tendiert man dazu, zu sagen, ne, weil einfach die letzten Spiele die Ergebnisse nicht stimmen. Jetzt das nächste Spiel ist dann in Paderborn. Da wird sich weisen, was da passiert, weil Paderborn hat eine breite Brust, muss nicht zwingend das Spiel jetzt derart bestimmen, weil sie einfach wissen, wir haben ein ordentliches Polster zwischen uns, aber Hannover muss schon was Themas mitnehmen aus Paderborn. Und dann haben sie, glaube ich, ein Restprogramm, das einigermaßen ginge, aber sie haben auch Punkte liegen lassen gegen Teams, wo man sagt, da müsste was drin sein. Also, ja, im Moment ist der Trend auf jeden Fall in die falsche Richtung ausschweifend. Und mal gucken, was da ist. Ich traue mir da bei Hannover echt noch gar keine Prognose für das Saisonende zu, weil es doch so diffus ist ein bisschen. Also, sie können jeden erdrücken, aber sie können auch hinten immer wieder Chancen eröffnen. Ja, diese Balance. That's it. Finde die Balance.
Prognose Wundertüte. Aber ich glaube, das muss den Verantwortlichen klar gewesen sein, dass es im ersten Jahr mit diesem Umbruch mit dem Trainer, dessen komplexe Spielidee vielleicht auch eine Zeit braucht, es auch nicht direkt hochgehen muss. Man hat da ja insgesamt eher jüngere Mannschaft, alle jetzt wahrscheinlich mit längeren Verträgen, weil neu gekommen. Ich würde jetzt mal behaupten, da flippt jetzt keiner aus, wenn man im ersten Saison unter Titz nicht aufsteigt und das dann eher in der zweiten Saison Gestalt annimmt. Man hat ja auch viele Führungsspieler verloren, also Ron Robert Zieler und Co. sind alle weg. Das bringt vielleicht auch manchmal was in die Zwangten und dann fehlen auch die letzten Prozentpunkte an Souveränität. Nele, bist du ein bisschen konkret an deiner Prognose oder weißt du auch nicht, wohin mit dir?
Damit ich an Weihnachten nicht rausgeschmissen werde, natürlich wird 96 Meister und steigt direkt auf.
Damit hast du deine ersten drei aber eigentlich schon voll.
Nein, mein kleiner Bruder sagt das seit zwei Jahren. Dieses Jahr, dieses Jahr. Ich weiß gar nicht woher, diese Delusionierung, was das Fußball angeht, kommt. Das liegt bei mir irgendwie in der Familie. Das ist eine Desillusionierung. Ich glaube, 96 ist wenn dann das Überraschungsteam, was auch Darmstadt noch überflügeln kann, wenn viele Sachen zusammenfallen. Der Spielplan spielt auf jeden Fall in die Karten von 96, würde ich sagen. Die haben dann halt dementsprechend natürlich, wenn es in Richtung Crunchtime, The Liga, so Richtung März, April, Mai geht, dann haben die natürlich das, also theoretisch, wenn das jetzt alles so bleibt, das entspannte Rörestprogramm, haben im März das Heimderby und dann halt Elvesberg, Darmstadt, Paderborn, Karlsruhe und hinten raus noch Münster, Bochum, Nürnberg. Also ich glaube, ich glaube, wenn, wenn dann, also wenn es ein Überraschungsaufsteiger, der halt oder beziehungsweise ein Überraschungsteam kommt, was so ein bisschen Dark Horse mäßig so ins Rennen noch eingreift, dann ist es 96, weil da jetzt nicht so wirklich jeder mit rechnet, weil da kommt auch das Thema Umfeld wieder zum Tragen. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass da jetzt mal von so ein bisschen Lokalpresse abgesehen, dass da irgendwie jeder unbedingt hinguckt, weil Hannover so geil ist, so. Also ja, deswegen, also ich glaube so zwischen, zwischen, zwischen, zwischen 3 und 6 ist irgendwie alles drin. Und wenn sie Glück haben und jetzt nicht sich noch krass irgendwelche Spieler verletzen, vielleicht holen sie auch im Winter den Überspieler, kann ich mir auch sehr gut vorstellen, dass sie da irgendwo aus der, weiß ich nicht, dritten, französischen, zweiten französischen Liga irgendwie so einen Top-Stürmer herholen, der die Bundesliga, die 2. Liga– kriegst noch nicht in deinen Kopf– die 2. Liga kurz und klein schießt, wird mich nicht wundern, wenn ich ehrlich bin.
Ne, also das Scouting jetzt im Sommer war ja auch krass.
War auch solide.
Also ja, erst mal solide, das hat wirklich Erfolg gewesen und man hat ja überall gefischt. Also man hat da anscheinend ja auch sehr viel umgestellt und dementsprechend ja, man hat im… Also und man ist so attraktiv als Standort, dass man so einen Spieler dann auch mal eher bekommt. Vielleicht weil auch in der Bundesliga einer vom Laster fällt oder so. Das kann ja passieren.
Also auch Tichler kommt jetzt nochmal aus einer Verletzung zurück. Vielleicht ist ja das dann auch für eine Doppelspitze… Wobei der auch kein Clipser ist. Nee, aber vielleicht tun sie sich doch als Duo ganz gut. Who knows?
Who knows? Ich know, dass wir jetzt über den KSC reden. Es ist als Moderator nicht immer ganz einfach, die Überleitung zu finden. Ich moderiere aber auch schon mal so an, ich glaube, dass wir nicht ewig über den KSC reden werden. Und das meine ich gar nicht dispektierlich, sondern wenn wir darauf blicken, was jetzt auch gegen Bielefeld passiert ist, da hat man nämlich eine 0 zu 4-Klatsche bekommen. Und man steht jetzt punktgleich mit Hannover, also mit 21 Zählern auf Rang 6. Das ist eben auch noch super für den KSC. Da brauchen wir gar nicht über reden, aber wir reden ja heute über das Aufstiegsrennen. Und unter der Prämisse, glaube ich, da greife ich jetzt mal vorweg, wird der KSC kein richtiges Wort mitreden. Das Spiel war die komplette 1. Halbzeit ausgeglichen gegen Bielefeld, doch dann brachten später Elfmeter und die 0 zu 1-Führung das Verderben ins Rollen, wenn man so möchte. Nach der Halbzeitpause, kurz danach, ist man wieder unaufmerksam als KSC, kassiert das 0 zu 2 und danach gibt man sich geschlagen und kassiert da nach 60 Minuten schon das 0 zu 4. Ein sehr gebrauchter Tag vom KSC, der nie wirklich in seinen Flow kam, sich dieses Mal auch nicht auf Wannizek verlassen konnte und dann defensiv auseinanderfiel. Ich nehme meine Bewertung vorweg und konfrontiere euch quasi damit und ihr könnt dann sagen, ob ihr das seht, so sieht oder nicht. Ich finde, dieses Spiel spricht irgendwie auch Bände darüber, wo man den Cast einordnen muss. Denn in meinen Augen reicht es für ganz oben rein qualitativ einfach nicht. Eichner holt in meinen Augen seit Jahren alles aus diesem insgesamt wenig ambitionierten, zusammengestellten Kader heraus. Im Sommer hat man wieder Abgänge gehabt. Wie Max weiß, kriegt er noch einen Bernat als Ersatz, der das super macht. Aber du verlierst oft eher individuelle Qualität, musst sie dann wieder aufbauen. Und wenn dieses Maximum, was Eichner aus diesem Kader herausholt, an einem Tag mal nicht da ist, zu 100%, und wenn Marvin Waniecek nicht einen guten Tag erwischt, dann gibt es in der Regel für den KSC leider keine Punkte. Und das liegt auch darin, dass der Kader quasi keine Breite hat. Also jeder Ausfall tut extrem weh. Und das ist alles grundsolide, was die machen, aber eben meist nicht mehr. Und deswegen sage ich jetzt schon mal, der KSC in meiner Welt definitiv wieder eine Mannschaft für die obere Tabellenhälfte. Und das ist wieder in Ordnung. Aber für ganz oben, Matthias, ich sehe es nicht.
Bin ich komplett bei dir. Also diese mangelnde Konstanz, die zieht sich ja wie ein roter Faden durch die bisherige Saison. Gleichwohl 21 Punkte. Insofern alles im Lot. Aber sie gewinnen in der Regel ihre Heimspiele und ausserz lassen sie einfach Punkte liegen. Also dass sie zweimal in Folge gewinnen. Ich glaube, das war erst einmal der Fall in der Spielzeit. Und ich hatte mich jetzt auch mit einem Kumpel verständigt vor der Aufnahme der Karlsruhe-Fans. Grüße gehen raus, der auch davon sprach, dass diese riesigen Schwankungen zwischen Begeisterung gegen Schalke, der Sieg in der letzten Minute vor heimischem Publikum, gefolgt jetzt von so etwas wie einem Totalausfall im Bielefeld. Das lässt schon viele Fans ein bisschen irritiert zurück und können sich da auch nicht so recht ein Reim drauf machen, wo es denn hingeht in der Saison. Aber ich kann auf das auch einzahlen, was du schon angedeutet hast. Im Endeffekt, der Kader war, glaube ich, am Anfang der Saison mehrmals nicht voll ausgeschöpft. Also wenn ich das so richtig in Erinnerung habe, dann war der Kader oftmals ausgedünnt, was sich da niederschlug. Und sie haben ja auch tatsächlich das Fable dafür, Jugendspieler noch einzubinden, wie eben ein Ben Fahd oder Ban Fahd, Pindu Bidrosa oder La Griszi. Da sind schon Jugendspieler am Start, aber die müssen natürlich auch erst reinwachsen. Das machen sie in Karlsruhe verdammt oft und verdammt gut, aber dennoch braucht es Zeit. Jetzt haben sie Verletzte, wie eben ein Ben Fahd, wie Egloff, wie Jung. Förster ist dazugekommen, der ja in Darmstadt letzte Saison gespielt hat, aber der, glaube ich, auch noch nicht so recht Fuß gefasst hat, der mit seinen Erfahrungen im Spiel sehr viel geben kann, mit seiner Ruhe, mit seiner Übersicht, aber er kann halt auch in Spielen komplett abtauchen. Und dann hilft der der Mannschaft überhaupt nicht. Und im Moment, glaube ich, hat er in Karlsruhe dem Spiel noch nicht so recht seinen Stempel aufdrücken können. Und ja, das ist einfach zu schwankend, zu wenig konstant, zu sehr auf Heimspiel-Punkte im Moment ausgelegt. Ich glaube, da haben sie sogar Platz 1 in der Heimtabelle. Aber auswärts fällt regelmäßig dann doch nicht so viel bei rum. Und es gibt wohl auch in der Darmstädte, in der Karlsruhe-Fanszene so ein bisschen eine Diskussion, was denn mit den Neuzugängen ist und warum die denn nicht mehr zum Zukommen. Genannt sei es Opitz, der gegen Bielefeld ja schon mal gleich angedeutet hat, was er mit seiner Schnelligkeit anrichten kann. Oder auch Fukuda, der Japaner, dass die nicht so eingebunden werden, wie es wohl bestimmte Fangruppen gerne hätten. Aber ich glaube, in den Kurzzeiten, die sie im Moment eingesetzt waren, haben sie auch nicht jetzt so viel bewirkt. Also sie deuten es an, aber vielleicht bräuchten sie einfach mehr Vertrauen und mehr Zeit, um da wirklich ein Faktor zu werden. Aber das Gesamtkonstrukt KSC steht ein bisschen so auf tönernen Füßen. Vielleicht würde ich es so sagen. Um da wirklich ein Spitzen-Team darzustellen, fehlt mir im Moment auch so ein bisschen die Fantasie. Und deshalb glaube ich, da ist noch ein bisschen was im Argen.
Und der Ton an der Fuß heißt eben Marej Wanićek, der nun mal einer der größten Unterschiedsspieler dieser Liga ist. Und es ist vollkommen normal, dass auch er mit jetzt auch 32 Jahren vielleicht nicht jedes Spiel an sein absolutes Maximum kommt oder sich Gegner darauf auch einrichten lassen. Ich fand jetzt Bielefeld gegen den Ball auch echt giftig. Die haben da die Linien echt schwer zugemacht, sodass diese Halbräume, die Wanićek will, gar nicht so oft gefunden werden konnten. Aber ja, du kannst ja auch Roko Simic nennen. Ich finde, diese Transfers, die wirken... Also, die sprechen nicht alle eine Sprache, die stehen für verschiedene Spielstile, die sind teilweise sehr spät gekommen. Du hast es gesagt, am Anfang haben die nicht mal einen 18er-Kader gestellt. Also, mir tut es manchmal fast leid bei Christian Eichner, weil ich den wirklich für einen fähigen Trainer halte, wirklich. Aber er muss jedes Jahr eigentlich bei 9 ansetzen, bei 0 oder teilweise sogar bei minus 1, weil gewisse Spieler dann gehen und der Kader sehr spät, mit wenig Geld zusammengestellt wird. Und ich frage mich so ein bisschen einfach nach wie vor, das habe ich auch mit der Saisonprognose gesagt, ich weiß nicht, wo der KSC hin will. Das strahlt für mich sportlich von der Führung her nichts aus. Ja, man bringt Projekte voran, wie es kommen ein paar mehr Jugendspieler hoch, man hat das Stadion fertig, spielt jetzt darin. Das sind gute Dinge, aber sportlich, was soll die Identität sein, wo soll es hingehen? Da fehlt mir irgendwie die Weitsicht. Und apropos Weitsicht, Nele, wie blickst du auf den KSC und was wäre dann auch deine Prognose? Wo soll es am Ende der Saison hingehen?
Ich könnte nicht weiter wechseln vom KSC, sowohl geografisch als auch fantechnisch. Weil es mir tatsächlich aufgefallen ist, wie unterschiedlich die beiden Halbzeiten waren. Die 1. Halbzeit war ja schon, dass sich beide Teams...
Solide.
Ja, beide Teams haben sich gut gegenseitig neutralisiert und es war trotzdem nicht langweilig. Das finde ich immer wichtig, wenn man Defensivarbeit sieht, die auch Spaß machen kann. Ich fand die beiden Dreierketten, das hat mir auch ganz gut gefallen, wie die gegen den Ball zu einer Fünferkette wurde, sowohl bei Bielefeld als auch beim KSC. Das fand ich ganz schön und es hat ganz gut funktioniert, aber auch nur beim KSC 40 Minuten lang, wenn man ehrlich ist. Gut, dann kommt eben dieser VAR-Eingriff und dieser Elfmeter, der das Spiel öffnet. Aber wenn du dann die zweite Halbzeit siehst, da ist ja wirklich, wie Bielefeld aus der Kabine kommt, das ist ja jetzt auch nichts Neues. Und jetzt haben wir wieder das böse Wort mit EM, dass das ein absolutes Mentalitätsteam ist. Und dann auch noch zu Hause. Das weiß man nicht erst seit gestern. Und dem DFB-Pokal, dass Bielefeld zu Hause einfach ein absolut überragendes Team ist. Ich fand es wirklich erschreckend, wie Bielefeld in viereinhalb Minuten Karlsruhe komplett auseinandergenommen hat. Und der KSC war immer einen Schritt zu langsam. Da wurden Bälle nicht ordentlich geklärt, sondern einfach nach vorne in die Mitte gechipt und gespielt. Und dann kann halt Handwerker einfach mal so ein Ball reinchippen. Und der geht dann halt einfach von Momolu, weil der halt einen Lauf hat, einfach rein. So, also die Verteidigung vom KSC in diesen fünf Minuten, in denen diese Treffer 2 und 3 für Bielefeld fallen, das war echt ein Leerstück für die Gruselkammer. Und man muss ja auch sagen, es hätte ja auch 5 zu 0, 6 zu 0 ausgehen können, weil die Chancen für Bielefeld waren da. Und dann sprechen wir noch mal ganz anders hier über Karlsruhe, weil wie gesagt, die erste Haltzeit war nicht schlecht und die war okay für das, was es denn am Ende ist. Und das bringt mich tatsächlich dann auch zu meinem, ich sag mal, Schafrichter-Urteil. Ich glaube, der KSC muss aufpassen, dass sie nicht ganz weit abrutschen, so in die Tabellenregionen 10, 11, 12, 13, wenn es so weitergeht.
Die Gefahr gibt es für ein Team wie den KSC auf jeden Fall, weil eben die Individualqualität nicht so da ist. Ich finde, auch in der ersten Haltzeit, du hast es angesprochen, ich fand sogar mit Ball, da gab es eine Struktur. Die wollen Fußball spielen und das rechne ich Christian Eichner an. Aber die Individualqualität ist krass. Und dann auch da, Bielefeld als Aufsteiger hat einen wesentlich breiteren Kader als der KSC in meinen Augen. Die können viel besser, effektiver nachlegen. Das Einzige, was irgendetwas gemacht hat bei dem KSC war Fuku da, der so ein bisschen mit seinem Tempo was gemacht hat. Ansonsten tut es mir leid, das reicht einfach nicht. Und dann weiß ich, man kann es nicht am Trainerfest machen, aber es wird nicht reichen, Punkt. Und deswegen sage ich ja, Erfolg wäre obere Tabellenhälfte. Es ist aber auch ein Team, was auf Platz 11 enden kann. Das ist ja auch schon passiert. Ich frage mich so ein bisschen, wo die lange Vision ist, aber das ist vielleicht etwas für eine andere Podcast-Episode. Deswegen lasst uns vielleicht einfach weitermachen.
Ich glaube, da würde ich noch einen kurzen Take zum Schluss machen. Und zwar hat mir auch mein Kumpel gesagt, dass wohl Eichner nach dem Spiel gegen Schalke gesagt hätte, er würde niemals seiner Mannschaft verbieten, auf Sieg zu spielen. Also gegen Kais Lautern haben sie zum Schluss verloren, vor eigenem Publikum, gegen Schalke gewonnen. Also es zeigt ja auch, wenn die Chance besteht, hier ein Dreier mitzunehmen, dann sind sie gewillt, das zu tun. Dann ist vielleicht aber auch hinten manchmal nicht die nötige Kompaktheit gegeben. Gestern war dann einfach nach der Halbzeit, wie Nele sagte, die Messe schnell gelesen. Wer so eine Spieleröffnung macht mit dem Anstoß, dass sechs Spieler nach vorne stürmen, fährt auf der Hände den Ball und dann ist 1 gegen 3. Und Momolu ist aber schneller im Kopf und auf den Beinen als alle anderen. Also Momolu und Goddowski, also Bielefeld hat eine Wucht. Das ist schon bemerkenswert.
Ja, aber das ist ja auch nichts Neues, oder? Genau, nee, absolut nicht. Klar, Eva, wir lieben dich und so, aber das ist doch jetzt wirklich nichts Neues mehr. Also ich finde, jetzt kann sich da kein Zweitligist mehr rausreden.
Nee, nee. Also deshalb, dass sich da Karlsruhe so unter Druck und überteufeln lässt, nicht nur bei dem 2-0, sondern auch vor dem 3-0 und vor dem 4-0, als sie einfach schlafen und die Ausführungen des Freistoßes gar nicht antizipieren. Also es war dann um sie geschehen. So kann man es, glaube ich, stehen lassen.
Absolut. Absolut. Gut, dann machen wir dieses Spiel und diesen Part zu und widmen uns dem letzten Spiel quasi, der Episode und damit auch den letzten beiden Teams. Denn wir reden jetzt über Kaiserslautern gegen Hertha BSC. Stimmiges Spiel da auf dem, oder ja, stimmungsvolles Spiel da auf dem Betze mit einer fantastischen Choreo zu 125 Jahre FCK. Das war schon beeindruckend, Hertha-Fans, aber auswärts wie immer auch stabil. Am Ende gewinnt Hertha dieses Spiel 1 zu 0. Ich würde mit Stefan Leitl mitgehen, der sagt, in den ersten 65 Minuten sind wir das klar bessere Team und müssen ja eigentlich das 2 und 3 zu 0 machen. Aber man macht es eben nicht und dadurch, und das hat er auch gesagt, gehören die letzten 25 Minuten wiederum den FCK. Der ist dann aber versäumt, eine seiner Chancen zu nutzen. Und so gewinnt Hertha dieses Spiel. Ich bleibe dabei, wenn man einfach wirklich chronologisch vorgeht und sieht, dass Hertha dieses Spiel eigentlich früher zu machen muss, verdient mit 1 zu 0. Und trotzdem kann man sich glücklich schätzen, dass man diese Endphase überlebt hat, auch wenn man das ja durch eigenes Zutun tut. Also Toni Leissner holt sich die 17. Platzwunde der Saison in diesem Spiel. Thiago Ernst hat irgendwie magische Hände im Sommer bekommen. Und plötzlich funktionieren diese Dinge. So steht der 1. FC Kaiserslautern, über den wir zuerst reden wollen, qua Tabelle mit 20 Punkten auf Rang 7. Es war die erste Heimliederlage der laufenden Saison und auch das 3. Liga-Spiel hintereinander ohne Sieg. Matthias, wie blicken wir denn auf dieses Spiel? Wo lagen die Probleme von Lautern und was lässt sich dadurch vielleicht auch für die gesamte Saison ablesen?
Ich denke, dass Hertha in ihren Aktionen sehr viel klarer war, sehr viel zielgerichteter Richtung Tor. Ich denke, das liegt in dem, was die Hertha einfach im Kader hat. Da können wir dann nachher darüber reden. Ich glaube auch, dass Thorsten Debugnecht schon genau wusste, dass es darauf ankommt, irgendeine Art von Restverteidigung aufzubieten, die diesem schnellen Umschaltspiel von Hertha was entgegenstellt. Aber ich glaube, vielleicht war auch so das ganze Setting ein bisschen zu überwältigend. Also das ganze Stadion war quasi am Brennen und dann nach 20 Minuten steht plötzlich 0 zu 1. Und das Stadion braucht nicht viel, um wieder Feuer zu fangen. Ich glaube, ein Latten-Treffer hätte schon gereicht, um wahrscheinlich sämtliche Lebensadern auf der Pfalz wieder zum Pulsieren zu bringen. Aber schlussendlich hat es die Hertha gut gemacht und die Lauter kamen nicht so in diese, also die Offensive von ihnen war gut abgestellt, finde ich. Also Tony Leisner, Man of the Match, so ein bisschen, weil an ihm kam nichts vorbei. Und die Hertha hat sehr gut verstanden, die Pluspunkte der Lauter auszubremsen. Also in Britannien war selten irgendwie gefunden worden. Jolide, der über rechts normalerweise das Spiel mitkriegiert und ankurbelt, war eigentlich gar nicht präsent. Dafür Haas auf der anderen Seite sehr viel mehr. Und ein Sküthe, der auch so in einem Spiel schon mal ein Stempel aufdrücken kann, war auch kein Faktor. Also sie haben es in letzter Konsequenz nicht verstanden oder geschafft, im letzten Drittel, sprich im Angriffstrittel, was zu kreieren, was die Hertha wirklich nachhaltig beschäftigt. Das war zum Schluss so, aber es war jetzt auch, korrigiert mich nicht so, dass da zwingend diese Chance in Tor sein muss.
Nö, es waren gute, brauchbare Chancen. Es waren keine hundertprozentigen dabei, würde ich behaupten. Und das fand ich von Sören Gonther auch im TV-Kommentar auch gut gesagt. Der sagt, man hat hier nicht das komplette Gefühl, dass das hier nochmal wegbricht für Hertha. So, das Gefühl entstand nicht, auch wenn in den letzten zehn Minuten der Betze immer eine Wucht entwickelt durch die Fans. Und trotzdem wirkte das etwas kühler als sonst. Nele, was hat der FCK für dich, ja, was für einen Eindruck hat er auf dich gemacht? Und wie blickst du auf die bisherige Saison?
Ich muss ganz kurz noch Thier Gernst einmal loben, weil ich fand, was der da teilweise weggefischt hat, war auch stabil und ich mag gute Torhüter. Aber Kaiserslautern, es ist einfach richtig bitter. Also trotz der Stimmung, so eine Heimniederlage zu kassieren, ich kenne das auch, das ist scheiße, das macht keinen Spaß. Man hat in diesem Spiel tatsächlich ganz gut gesehen, der Abstand zu Hertha ist tatsächlich nur minimal, aber dieses minimale reicht halt, um dann eben nicht doch noch den Ausgleich zu schießen. Es gab ja dann einen Treffer, der vom VR aberkannt wurde, und ich habe die Stimmung nur übers Radio mitbekommen, aber das war krass. Ich fand das in der Audio-Reportage schon sehr, sehr eindrücklich. Ich finde, man sieht bei Kaiserslautern sehr viel, was so ein Traditionsclub ausmacht, viel Leidenschaft. Und wenn du halt einen Heimvorteil hast, dass die Kombinativ-Fehlen die Halbräume spielen. Das gefällt mir bei Kaiserslautern so über die Saison bisher ganz gut, aber nach vorne fehlt halt einfach die letzte Idee und die Präzision im letzten Drittel. Und das reicht dann gegen Teams wie Hertha einfach nicht.
Ich fand auch, das Spiel hat eigentlich lauter das größte Problem bislang aufgezeigt, generell unter Thorsten Lieberknecht. Was passiert, wenn der Gegner sich etwas tiefer fallen lässt und sich nicht auf das so offene Spiel einlässt, was lautern will? Weil das entscheiden sie dann über Dynamik und Wucht und Robustheit. Anders gesagt, es fehlt ein wenig der Plan B im dann statischeren Ballbesitz. Und dann kommt man– also gegen Hertha ist man quasi nicht in die Tiefe gekommen und hat dementsprechend auch nicht die Flankenposition bekommen, die man für den Pretanien haben möchte, auch weil dann zur Not schädelt halt Tony Leissner Pretanien mit aus dem Strafraum. Gar kein Problem. Aber da hatte man keine Antwort darauf. Und Stefan Leitwil hat das nach dem Spiel gesagt. Man hat bewusst einen anderen Ansatz gewählt, um Lautern zu überraschen und sie vor Aufgaben zu stellen. Man hat tiefer gestanden und ist deutlich mehr auf Umschaltmomente gegangen. Deswegen hat Winkler statt Krattmacher gespielt. Winkler ist schneller als Krattmacher. Deswegen hat Lukas Schula im Mittelsturm gespielt und nicht Sebastian Gröning. Das hat viel überrascht, weil Schula in vielen Dingen schlechter ist als Gröning, aber er ist schneller. Und da hat man die Umschaltmomente gesucht. Mit dem Glas-Kolbe zudem noch einen Links-Verteidiger gebracht, der mit 1.96 natürlich auch zur Not noch mal helfen kann. Und das er sehr gut gemacht hat, also Jolie aus dem Spiel zu nehmen, weil er in den letzten Wochen auch nicht jedem vergönnt. Und dann fragt man sich bei Krasus-Lautern, was kommen soll. Und das ist, glaube ich, Matthias, du kennst Torsten Lieberknecht sehr gut aus Darmstadt. Statischer Ballbesitz ist nun nicht seine Stärke.
Nee, und da hätte ich aber gedacht, dass so jemand wie Marlon Ritter durch seine Hereinnahme durchaus mal was kreieren kann. Also es hat schon gereicht, dieser eine Freistoß, den er dann haas auflegt in den Lauf. Und dann kam eben die Situation als Leistner auf der Linie im Flughafen weil klärt. Also das heißt, dass Marlon Ritter schon so ein ausgebufftes Schlitzer ist, das mal, glaube ich, auch aus Dingen was kreieren kann, wo es eben ein Verfahren ist, die Situation. Deshalb habe ich das verstanden, dass er an der Stelle sicherlich irgendwie ein Ausweg aus der Situation sein soll. Aber zählbares kam dabei dann tatsächlich doch nicht bei RUM. Und wir alle haben ja wahrscheinlich das Nachspiel-Interview mit Lieberknecht gehört. Also ich habe es bei RCL gesehen. Der war kein guter Verlierer, muss man so zu sagen. Und er hatte auch jetzt gestern ein Interview, zumindest wurde es gestern veröffentlicht, auf ncv.de gegeben. Und da sprach er tatsächlich davon, dass es für ihn schon ein Lebenstraum darstellen würde, durch seine eigene Biografie. Und in dem Wissen, was der FCK, der Stadt bedeutet, die in die Bundesliga irgendwann zurückführen zu können. Und er sprach davon, den Leuten die Rückkehr in die Bundesliga zu schenken. Und ich glaube, wenn er einfach sieht, was da vor dem Spiel abgerissen wurde auf den Tribünen, dann war das für ihn einfach emotional too much. Ja, also er hat…
Ich wollte gerade sagen, ja.
Für ihn war das wahrscheinlich dann einfach auch so ein bisschen, ich habe die Leute ja heute enttäuscht. Und ich glaube, das wollte er sich nicht so ganz eingestechen im ersten Moment und dann kam so ein Interview zustande, wie es eben jetzt endete, weil er schon manchmal eben das Herz auf der Zunge trägt.
Nicht alle werden es mitbekommen haben. Er hat sich nach dem Spiel sehr emotional über den Videoschiedsrichter, den Videobeweis aufgeregt, sprach davon, das wäre auf der PlayStation, er möchte diese Bilder schon gar nicht mehr sehen. Und auch da, es gab jetzt viele Diskussionen, Lukas Kwasniok und Eugen Polanski haben auch Dinge zum VR gesagt. Und wir können sehr gerne über den Videoschiedsrichter als solchen reden, aber in dieser Situation, das Abseits von Parteien, eigentlich müsste das schon der geschulte Ligienrichter sehen, weil es war nicht so knapp. Wir reden nicht von dem zu langen Fußnagel, wie jetzt beispielsweise bei Union gegen Bayern, sondern es war eine klare Abseits-Situation. Und wir können gerne drüber reden, in wie vielen Situationen das schiefgeht, aber ich finde Abseits- und Tor-Linien-Technologie, das ist doch eine gute Sache. Das ist doch eine gute Sache und da gibt es auch keinen Halbschwanger. Wenn jemand im Abseits steht, selbst wenn es knapp ist, wir können über da auch wieder Margin of Error reden, es gibt einen Toleranzbereich, ja. Aber in dem Fall hätte kein Toleranzbereich der Welt etwas anders entschieden, dann noch darüber zu reden, dass die Nachspielzeit war nicht lang genug und jeder Fifty-Fifty-Entscheidung wurde gegen uns gefiffen. Also bei aller Liebe. Und ich glaube auch, Matthias, das kommt aus einer zu krassen Verbissenheit in dem Moment. Fand ich auch unangemessen.
Ja, genau. Ja, also haben wir auch in Darmstadt schon erlebt. Ich konnte ihn auch dreimal in Summe interviewen. Also er ist ein sehr, sehr sensibler Charakter. Er ist zugewandt, er ist nahbar. Also wenn man sich mit ihm, glaube ich, abseits von 90 Minuten und drum herum unterhält, dann ist er einer der wahrscheinlich gewinnendsten Charaktere im Fußballbusiness. Aber er kann dann halt manchmal nicht auf seine Haut. Und das hat man gestern dann erlebt. Und natürlich hast du, ich habe es mir jetzt noch mal notiert, in den letzten 20 Minuten 8 zu 0 Torschüsse. Wir haben es gerade erwähnt, da waren jetzt nicht die Hochkaräter per se dabei. Auch so die taktische Disziplin ist zum Schluss einfach über Bord geworfen worden. Man hat dann einfach gesagt, alles nach vorne und irgendwie ab dafür. Vielleicht mal eine Personalie zu nennen, die mir gestern ganz gut gefallen hat, war Shahin. Also der einfach als Übergangsspieler zwischen Defensive und Offensive sehr wichtig ist. Sowas gab es jetzt in der Form gestern im Hertha-Spiel nicht. Jemand, der an der Stelle einfach einen Ball auch mal schleppt und dadurch auch mal Seitenverlagerungen macht oder sowas. Den fand ich zumindest schon mal sehr auffällig. Den kennen wir noch letztes Jahr aus Elbersberg. Aber der hat sich da glaube ich schon sofort ein ganz gutes Standing erarbeitet in der Mannschaft. Und letzte Woche war auch, es gibt ja immer diese Social Media Clips der Vereine, da wurde jeder, der vor die Kamera kam, gefragt, wer denn der unterschätzte Zweitligaspieler wäre. Und da hat er dann gesagt, Semmy Schahin. Einfach so im Vorbeigehen, ohne lang zu überlegen. Also, ich denke, da kann einem Spiel der Lauter schon was geben. Die haben schon auch interessante Charaktere im Team. Also, so jemand wie der Sküthe finde ich, jemand, der Marlon Ritter auf die Bank verdrängt, der hat schon was drauf und der hat ja auch wichtige Tore schon erzielt. Und wenn du Marlon Ritter bringen kannst, und der die Situation annimmt, dann kann das auch nicht verkehrt sein. Aber ich glaube, in Lautern ist doch ein bisschen zu viel Drama und Emotionen im Spiel. Als dass die bis zum Schluss wirklich den 1. Liga-Aufstieg irgendwie klar machen oder so. Das wäre im Moment so mein Take an der Stelle.
Es ist interessant, und es zeigt sich auch in den Spielen. Es passiert immer wieder, dass der FCK 3 oder sogar 4 Tore schießt. Aber gleichzeitig gab es auch schon sieben Spiele, wo man nur ein oder gar kein Tor erzählt hat. Also es ist oft dieses Explosionsartige. Aber wenn die Explosion nicht kommt, dann kommt auch gar nichts. Sondern du hast keine Varianzen im Spiel, auch mal durch die Mitte beispielsweise. Das erinnert mich ein bisschen an die erste Saison von Hertha und der Paldada in der 2. Liga. Entweder ist gar nichts gelungen, oder man hat durch Tabakowitsch und Reze Gegner 5 zu 0 besiegt. Nede, du weißt auch, da hat man Schalke, glaube ich, einmal richtig hergespielt. Aber das war dann drei Spieltage wieder nicht zu sehen, weil halt da der Knoten nicht geplatzt ist. Und für mich ist das ein Team der ersten sieben, aber nicht wirklich eines der ersten drei Plätze, um das vorwegzunehmen. Aber Nele, wie ist dein Blick darauf?
Ja, Kaiserslautern ist eine richtige Achterbahn-Mannschaft. Ich habe noch dieses 1-2-1 in Düsseldorf da im Hinterkopf, was auch völlig absurd wild war, wie das ganze Spiel so war. Jetzt gegen Hertha fand ich noch ganz interessant, dass Kaiserslautern viel mehr Ballbesitz hatte und fast 200 Pässe mehr gespielt hat als Hertha. Aber die sind halt nicht angekommen. Das ist auch so ein Ding, was da mit reinspielt. Es ist das aktivere Team, es ist das Heimteam. Die haben 16 Schüsse abgegeben, aber davon sind halt auch nur, jetzt muss ich kurz gucken, 9 aufs Tor gegangen. Das sind dann halt einfach wieder solche Statistiken, die zeigen, da ist auf jeden Fall was dahinter und da ist auf jeden Fall was da, was auch nach vorne möchte, aber das funktioniert, es reicht halt einfach nicht. Und das ist, glaube ich, auch so ein bisschen meine Conclusio in Bezug auf Kaiserslautern. Ja, so zwischen 5 und 8, vielleicht 10, wenn es schlecht läuft, weil du hast halt Spiele wie– jetzt muss ich noch mal kurz auf die Dings gucken– du hast ja teilweise Spiele drin wie dieses 2-3 gegen Karlsruhe, was vom neunten Spieltag war, das war auch anderswild. Und dann hast du halt aber auch einen glücklichen 1-0-Sieg im Pokal gegen Fürth und halt eben dieses 1-1 gegen Düsseldorf und jetzt diese Niederlage gegen Hertha. Also da ist halt irgendwie alles drin. Achterbahn.
Achterbahn.
Gegen Nürnberg haben sie gleich wohl im letzten oder vorletzten inzwischen Heimspiel 1-0 geführt, lange Zeit, und dann in der Nachspielzeit durch den Elfmeter ein Ausgleich rasiert. Also da haben sie es dann auch nicht verstanden, den Sack zuzumachen, auch wenn es ein bisschen schmeichelhaft wohl war. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, sie müssen versuchen, diese Wucht des Betzenbergs irgendwie zu kultivieren und auch immer mal nach außen mitzunehmen. Ansonsten, ja, wie ich sagte, das ist ein bisschen zu viel Emotionen und vielleicht dann manchmal nicht so der klare Verstand.
Klare Verstand, da kriege ich keine Überleitung zu Hertha hin. Das geht nicht. Das ist unmöglich.
Vielleicht Klarheit, weil einfach die Hertha jetzt korrigieren mich, aber sie haben ja durchaus verstanden, worauf sie in der 2. Liga inzwischen ankommt. Ich glaube, das ist der Schlüssel. Lange Zeit haben sie vorne keine Tore geschossen, jetzt kriegen sie schon lange hinten keine mehr rein. Also ich glaube, sie haben einfach die richtigen Schlüsse gezogen. Aber du bist näher dran.
Du sprichst da auf jeden Fall einschlüsselnd das Erfolgs an. Das 1 zu 0 war jetzt der vierte Sieg in Folge. Zeigt euch der vierte in Folge ohne Gegentor. Man hat sieben der letzten neun Spiele gewonnen. Steht jetzt mit 20 Punkten auf Rang 8 und nur noch drei Ziele hinter dem Redigationsrang, der zwischenzeitlich gefühlt schon– also, das war abgeschrieben. Und die Mannschaft hat extrem Auftrieb, die Dinge klicken endlich ineinander und die Spieler entwickeln ein aktuell unerschütterlich wirkendes Selbstverständnis. Und man hat das Gefühl, man hat endlich nachhaltig– und ich setze ein Ausrufzeichen hinter nachhaltig– verstanden, was es in der 2. Liga braucht, um die Basis für die individuellen Glanzmomente zu schaffen. Denn die hat– man hat ja die individuelle Qualität, aber die ist wirklich egal– und das haben mir schon viele Absteiger gezeigt– wenn du nicht die Grundtugen in der 2. Liga annimmst, die Stefan Leithel seit seinem Amtsantritt immer wieder aufführt. Also Kampf, Leidenschaft, Wille, Einsatz. So, das ist ganz einfach. Und ja, was ist passiert? Ich kann natürlich ganz weit ausholen, aber also, der Katastrophensaisonstart ist bis heute nicht so ganz erklärlich, weil nichts darauf hingedeutet hat. Denn die Rückrunde unter Stefan Leithel, als er kam, war ja wirklich mehr als solide. Und dann begann das ganze Unheil, ja, mit, wie gesagt, dieser Niederlage auf Schalke und ging wirklich ähnlich dramatisch schlecht weiter. Stefan Leithel führt das immer wieder auf die Verletzten zurück, wo ich sage, ja, es gab Verletzte, die haben vielleicht gewisse Dinge erklärt, sie haben aber nicht den Grad der Schlechtheit erklärt, mit der Hertha in dieser Saison gestartet ist. Aber man muss Stefan Leithel insofern recht geben, als dass, als dann Verletzte zurückgekehrt sind, sich bei Hertha etwas verändert hat. Auch mit dann einer Systemumstellung, das war im Spiel gegen Elbersberg, da hat man dann endlich von Dreier- auf Viererkette umgestellt, hat Fabian Reese auf den Flügel gestellt, nicht mehr in den Mittelsturm und das hat schon viele Dinge verändert. Dann ist zum Beispiel das 3-0 gegen Hannover vom Laster gefallen. Und so hat man sich erste, oft schmeichelhafte, nicht immer systematisch wirkende Siege geholt, die aber Druck genommen haben, die der Mannschaft geholfen haben und allmählich hat sich diese Mannschaft dann daraus befreit und immer wieder so ein Sieg geholt, wo man so war, also es gäbe vom Ai was nicht, aber Hauptsache erstmal Gewinn und Stabilität in die Saison bekommen. Und da muss man sagen, Stefan Leithel hat Ruhe bewiesen, Stefan Leithel hat gearbeitet, Stefan Leithel hat einen Zugang zu dieser Mannschaft gefunden und das haben in den letzten Jahren, hat das kein Trainer nachhaltig geschafft. Und das sieht man Beispiel an Marthondarday. Marthondarday war zum Beginn der Saison nicht wieder zu erkennen. Der war eine Gefahr für sich selbst. Der wurde im Heimspiel ausgeboot, wenn er am Ball war geführt. Das war wirklich krass. Und er hat ja nun viel Kredit als Berliner, Hertha-Naday, so und so. Und Stefan Leidel hat ihm weiter vertraut. Und hat irgendwann letztens gesagt, ich habe dem im persönlichen Gespräch gesagt, ich halte ihn für einen Ausnahmespieler in der 2. Liga, ich habe Vertrauen in dich, mach weiter. Und Marthondarday hat weitergemacht und sieht jetzt aktuell wie einer der besten Innenverteidiger dieser Liga aus. Thiago Ernst, letzte Saison, nicht gut gewesen. Diese Saison der statistisch beste Torhüter dieser Liga. Und du kannst die Liste so weitergehen und jetzt, und dann kommen so Spieler zurück wie Paul Seguin, Diego Demme, die dann zusätzlich, ne der lacht schon bei dem Namen Paul Seguin ab, Paul Pinguin, der nicht wohl gelitten ist auf Schalke, der aber unter Stefan Leitl, also ich hab auch mir damals die Zahlen auf Schalke angeguckt und war so, also Freunde, an ihm lag's nicht, aber ist egal.
Doch.
Ja, er war der einzige Schuldige. Alle anderen haben geliefert, nur Paul Seguin, nicht?
Ja.
Genau. Nee, aber seit seiner Rückkehr ist er voll da. Diego Demme sieht besser aus, als er jemals auch sah bei Hertha. Und Stefan Leitl hat da jetzt einen Umschwung hinbekommen, der sich darin abbildet, dass man mittlerweile, er sagte diesen schönen Satz vor dem Spiel gegen Dresden, das war das letzte Spiel der Englischen Woche, da hatten die einen Journalist gefragt, ob es denn jetzt, ob er irgendeinen Bonus, irgendeine besondere Belohnung hätte, wenn man das letzte Spiel der Englischen Woche auch noch gewinnt. So, man müsste das ja feiern. Und er guckt den an und sagt in seiner nüchternen, trockenen Art, die Stefan Leitl immer hat, nö. Und führt dann aber weiter aus und sagt, es muss endlich Normalität werden für uns, Spiele zu gewinnen. Und das ist so ein Satz, der klingt so banal, aber der ist bei Hertha nicht banal, weil zuletzt Siege immer gefeiert wurden wie sonst was und auch den Spielern das Alibi gegeben haben, sich darauf erst mal drei Wochen auszuruhen und zu sagen, naja, aber wir haben ja schon bewiesen, dass wir es können. Und Stefan Leitl ist das aber egal, sondern er setzt jedes Spiel neu an und die Mannschaft folgt ihm endlich, weil sie verstanden hat. Und plötzlich sehen einige Spieler aus wie ausgewechselt. Mikael Cresens ist endlich wieder der Alte. Und interessanter Nebeneffekt, man ist so unabhängig von Fabian Reese wie noch nie. Ja, er ist ein Faktor im Hertha-Spiel. Nicht ohne Grund hat er schon ein paar Vorlagen, aber er ist längst nicht mehr der Faktor. Und das macht Hertha natürlich auch weniger ausrechenbar. Mehr Spieler treten in Verantwortung. Und dementsprechend hat man tatsächlich das Gefühl, dass Hertha– also die sind da. Das fühlt sich komisch an zu sagen, weil man diesen Frieden bei Hertha nie trauen möchte. Weil man immer das Gefühl hat, eigentlich ist es nicht nachhaltig. Aber die Zahlen, die ich am Anfang, die Statistiken, die ich am Anfang vorgelesen habe, zeigen, dass da wirklich was nachhaltig geklickt hat. Und dann, wenn eine Mannschaft wie Hertha BSC mit der individuellen Qualität anfängt, die Grundtugenden der Zweitliga abzurufen, dann ist es wirklich kein Hot-Take, dass sie unter die ersten drei gehört. Deswegen haben sie ja so viele unter die ersten drei getippt am Anfang der Saison und man läuft dem natürlich noch ein Stück weit hinterher, aber es ist greifbarer geworden. Und es fehlen ja immer noch viele Spieler. Also du hast immer noch keinen David Kufnacki beispielsweise.
Und damit dieser Monolog jetzt mal kurz unterbrochen wird, fasse ich das jetzt alles noch mal zusammen. Hertha fährt den Sieg clever nach Hause. Nicht spektakulär, aber effektiv genug für die 2. Liga.
Und daran war nicht zu denken, dass Hertha so einen Kampfsieg mal effizient runterspielt. Das konnten die gar nicht. So. Hertha konnte entweder spektakulär alles ineinanderklicken oder sie sahen aus, als ob sie sich gerade vom Spiel das erste Mal gesehen hätten. Und jetzt hat man so eine innere Ruhe.
Stabile Zweitligamannschaft.
Ist das nicht verrückt? Ja. Und Stefan Leitel und Hertha, das funktioniert jetzt auf einmal. Und das, muss man sagen, zwischenteilig hatte selbst ich nicht mehr die Fantasie, dass das so sein könnte.
Ja, ich meine, Leitel ist ja auch kein Greenhorn in der Liga. Er kennt die, er weiß in- und auswendig, worauf es ankommt. Er ist mit der Viertel- und Erste-Liga aufgestiegen, mit Hannover blieb ihm jetzt der große Wurf verwehrt. Aber dennoch ist er einer der wahrscheinlich gefragteren Personalien auf dem Trainerstuhl in der 2. Liga, in jedem Fall. Und deshalb kommt es jetzt vielleicht im Saisonverlauf doch nicht so unüberraschend, dass das irgendwann doch nochmal klickt. Und wenn man eben so eine Doppel-Sechs hat, wie Seguin und Demis sie darstellen kann und man mit Eichhorn ein sehr, sehr stabiles Talent hat, dann ist da vielleicht schon mal eine norwegische Position auf dem Feld einfach safe. Du weißt, auf die kannst du dich verlassen und die herum finden auch immer Werleute, Vertrauen und Sicherheit. Und ich glaube, Eichhorn hat sich gestern in seinem 10. Spiel schon die 5. Gelbe abgeholt oder sowas. Also mit 16 auch schon mal gut im Zweikampf unterwegs oder manchmal ein bisschen drüber. Dafür habe ich ihn zu wenig gesehen bislang, aber er macht natürlich Schlagzeilen.
Ja, also Kenneth Eichhorn ist natürlich ein Thema für sich, weil er ja auch frische 16 ist. Er durfte in der Saisonvorbereitung nicht mal die Testspiele machen, weil er dann noch 15 war. Absolutes Ausnahmetalent, der eigentlich dadurch besticht, was er alles nicht macht. Denn er macht keine Leichtsinnsfehler. Er auch in Fouls, also die gelben Karten kommen eher, weil er vielleicht clever mal das Foul zieht oder so, aber es ist nie jetzt überstürmisch oder ähnliches. Der ist ad hoc auf Zweitliganiveau angekommen. Und welche größere Auszeichnung kann es geben, als wenn dein Trainer, trotz Optionen wie Seguin und Demme, sagt, die Frage ist, wer spielt neben Eichhorn? Weil er instinktiv schon so viele Dinge richtig macht. Das ist absurd. Bin gespannt, wie lange er ihn halten kann. Aber stand jetzt ist er. Es ist ein total wichtiger Punkt, Matthias. In den letzten zwei Jahren hatte Hertha kein gutes Zentrum, kein gutes Herz im Spiel quasi. Und das kriegt gerade Stefan Leitel hin. Und man sagt ja auf dem Fußball, wer das Zentrum gewinnt, gewinnt das Spiel. Und Hertha gewinnt halt immer öfter das Zentrum. Und da ist tatsächlich, kennet Eichhorn wirklich ein Faktor. Und das ist für 16 Jahre wirklich irre.
Ich habe gerade noch mal nachgesehen, da hat er die Gelbe in der 38. gekriegt und bleibt trotzdem bis zur 60. drauf. Also man traut ihm auch zu, dann so verantwortungsvoll mit der Situation umzugehen, wie es eben gilt, sie anzunehmen, die Situation. Und du hast recht, der ist gerade mal 3 Monate 16. Also aberwitzig. Und du hattest vorhin auch in einem Halbsatz erwähnt, das Winklern der Geschwindigkeit mitbringt. Den fand ich gestern auch sehr gewinnbringend. Also er hat einfach lauter einen Weg getan mit seinen Flügelläufen und hat ja dann auch, glaube ich, das Tor aufgelegt. Also sehr gut. Hat mir gefallen, wie Hertha das Spiel angegangen ist und vorausgesehen hat. Und dann auch schlussendlich knapp, aber das Spiel gezogen hat.
Ja, Stefan Leitel ist halt wirklich ein sehr guter, also er hat sehr gute Matchpläne. Das war bloß am Anfang der Saison einfach nicht erkenntlich, weil die Mannschaft in dieses absolute Loch gefallen ist und dem nicht folgen konnte. Die waren viel zu sehr in den Köpfen mit sich selbst und dem Druck beschäftigt. Und jetzt, wo diese Basis da ist und die Spieler nicht mehr panisch in die Partien gehen, sondern mit einem klaren Kopf, siehst du auch beispielsweise das Spiel gegen Elbersberg, das war auch durch einen klaren Matchplan gewonnen. Das Spiel in Hannover wurde durch einen klaren Matchplan gewonnen und so war es jetzt eben auch in Kaiserslautern. Ich will nicht sagen, dass alles jetzt schon perfekt ist. Es gibt viele Bereiche, in denen man sich noch verbessern kann. Spiel mit Ball ist teilweise noch nicht flüssig genug. Man kommt teilweise noch nicht strukturiert genug ins letzte Drittel, aber das sind ja die Dinge, an denen kann man arbeiten. Das sind oft auch die letzten Dinge, an denen man arbeitet. Da sind die anderen Grundtugenden viel wichtiger und das ist eingesickert. Das ist schon eine sehr stabile Basis. Deswegen auch da nochmal der Punkt. Hertha hat jetzt mit Lautern den letzten Gegner von oben gehabt. Ich lese mal kurz das Programm bis hinrunden Ende vor, ohne zu sagen, dass man all diese Spiele gewinnen wird. Aber es ist vielleicht einfacher. Man spielt jetzt noch gegen Braunschweig, Kiel, Magdeburg, Fürth und Bielefeld. Und zu Hause gegen Bielefeld, also immerhin nicht auf der Alm. Das ist ja noch mal ein anderer Schnack, wie wir jetzt wissen.
Der letzte Spieltag, der allerletzte ist dann allerdings auf der Alm. Da ist vielleicht dann auch schon die Messe gezwungen.
Ja, Eva und ich schmieden Pläne, dass wir vielleicht vor Ort... Wir werden die Podcast-Aufnahme machen, wenn Hertha dann doch noch den Aufstieg verspielt hat. Mal gucken. Nein, aber ich will sagen…
Oh, da wäre ich gern Soundgast.
Ja.
Und dann kommen wir, damit ich jetzt nicht schon wieder zu lange am Stück rede, Nele, was ist denn dein Eindruck von der…
Mein Hot-Tick zu Hertha?
Genau, dein Hot-Tick zur Gefestigtheit der alten Dame und wo es bis Saisonende hinführen kann.
Ja, ich muss das leider… Ich bin ja also… Ich würde gerne was anderes sagen, aber ich glaube, Hertha schafft es dieses Jahr wirklich. So ein bisschen der HSV-Fluch, den der Hertha jetzt mit hochzieht, weil ich glaube, es wird nie wieder so… Es wird ein 2. Liga-Team geben, wo die Fans so sehr leiden müssen wie beim HSV. Und deswegen kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass Hertha das dieses Jahr noch zieht, wie man so schön sagt.
Matthias, wie ist es mit dir und dein Bauchgefühl?
Also, Mannschaft der Stunde so ein bisschen neben Parabon hatten wir ja schon eingangs gesagt. 12 Punkte aus den letzten fünf Spielen. Das Momentum ist auf der Seite der Hertha. Die Messages scheinen angekommen zu sein, aber dennoch sind es auf Platz zwei immer noch sieben Punkte. Und ich glaube, Hertha will nicht dritter werden. Also, im Endeffekt gilt es, irgendwie zweiter zu werden und da ist schon noch eine gehörige Distanz zu überwinden. Deshalb wird es, auch wenn es im Moment alles aufzugehen scheint, alles andere als einfach. Dennoch hatte ich vor der Saison die Hertha auch auf den Aufstiegsplatz getippt und ich sage, sie waren mit Parabon und Schalke zusammen, auf jeden Fall die drei Teams, die sind für mich im Moment diejenigen, die mit Hannover sind, vielleicht die vier. Also ich drücke mich gerade um eine eindeutige Aussage, aber ich glaube, Hertha wird auf jeden Fall bis zum Saisonende vorneheran gerobbt sein und dann sind wir einfach mal in ab 8 Stellungen, was da passiert.
Und dass wir nicht einer Mannschaft gesagt haben, klarer Platz 1 für mich, jetzt schon 2. Ligameister, spricht ja dafür, wie eng diese Liga ist. Sechs verschiedene Tabellenführer in dieser Saison sprechen auch dafür, wie eng diese Liga ist. Also es bleibt spannend, wir werden das weiter beobachten. Und dann ist es an der Zeit, jetzt endlich aus dieser Folge zu führen. Sie ist lang genug geworden, aber es hat ja Spaß gemacht. Also an dieser Stelle, Matthias, Nele, vielen lieben Dank. Es hat großen Spaß gemacht mit euch und eurer Expertise. Ansonsten unterstützt ihr im Podcast auf rasenfunk.de/unterstützen. Mein Name ist Marc Jutzki und das war diese wunderbare Folge ums Aufstiegsrennen.
Tschüss.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.